well a vector is represented by an arrow
and it has both magnitude which is
represented by its length how long the
vector is and also by the direction
which is you know the angle which way
the vector is pointing or which way the
force is being exerted for example so
here we have two points in the
coordinate plane and we want to find the
vector that goes from this point to this
point so if I represent that as a vector
okay which is just drawn as an arrow
okay this is called the initial point
starting point this is called the
terminal point where it terminates or
stops and to find the component form of
a vector what you want to do is you want
to take the terminal point minus the
initial point so I'll just write that
down here so a terminal point where it
terminates or stops minus initial so
where it initiates or begins so what we
would do is we would say 7 minus 2
three minus one so all I did is I
subtracted the X's and I subtracted the
Y's and if we simplify we get five comma
two and that just means that you're
going right five in the horizontal
direction up to and that's your vector
right there so five two and notice we're
using these triangular brackets just to
differentiate from a coordinate point
where we'd have the the parentheses the
curved brackets so this is a vector this
is component form and again with these
vectors what you can do is if I took
this vector and I drew it down here or I
drew it over here these vectors would be
equivalent to one another because they
both all of them have the same
horizontal distance and vertical
distance they're both going right five
up to right five up to right five up to
what you don't want to do is you don't
want to make the vector longer these
would not be equivalent vectors and you
don't want to change the angle or the
direction of the vector these would not
be equivalent vectors so as long as it
has the same component form the vectors
are equivalent just meaning that you
know the forces exerted the same
direction with the same amount of force
or magnitude so this has been how to
find a component form of a vector I'll
see you in the next video